we begin with this developing story the
search is on right now for two people
accused of kidnapping a woman
and keeping her in captivity in parump
possibly for months
a message on social media helped lead
nye county sheriff's deputies
to the address where that victim was
being held our hector mejia is live this
afternoon with details on this bizarre
case hi hector what can you tell us
hey there well the night county
sheriff's office began investigating
this case
back in october with the help from the
metropolitan police department's missing
persons unit they were not able to find
the woman until last friday
when they got a call from the victim's
mother this afternoon authorities are
looking for
49 year old keith holman and 36 year old
kristen faff take a good look at your
screen
they're wanted for kidnapping
investigators accused holmen and theft
of taking a woman to pahrump and forcing
her to do manual labor
if she refused police say she was beaten
detectives rescued the woman from a
building that had barred windows
steel doors and barricades blocking the
doors it was also surrounded by cameras
and on friday the victim's mother called
police with a tip that eventually led to
her discovery
said that her daughter was messaging her
on facebook this was the first time
anyone had heard from the victim since
she went missing in las vegas in march
of 2020.
while communicating through facebook the
victim was able to describe the
residence in which she was being held
and nye county sheriff's deputies and
detectives began searching that area
and they found her both holmen and phaf
are facing charges of second-degree
kidnapping
false imprisonment involuntary servitude
and conspiracy
police say they would leave the woman
locked in the home with very little food
for several days at a time
holmen is also accused of sexually
assaulting the woman in 2018
and the couple is known to travel
frequently between las vegas and perramp
if you see them
you are asked to call police they are
considered armed and dangerous
reporting here mlk and alta hector mejia
8 news now